I'm currently at Tel Aviv airport.
Probably wondering what I'm doing here.
I've come to visit Masha. Like I heard
so much horrible stories that it was
kind of put me off from visiting
beforehand. But now I feel like I should
share this positive story.
>> Just to explain the gratitude and the
happiness that this brother of ours is
facing. Just 10 minutes ago, he couldn't
stand. Alhamdulillah. through your
donations to forever today. Not only is
he standing but he has a smile on his
face
to each and every one of you who
dignified our brother, our father from
donate to forever and help change lives
today.
[music]
Asalam alalaykum welcome to brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Hope you guys
are well inshallah. So here is a video
that I came across uh subhan Allah sent
to me by a brother of a sister who um is
a Muslim sister who's gone to Israel um
stolen land. It's is Palestine. Uh and
here is her sharing how pleasant her
experience was. Now there's different
kind of reactions on social media. I
heard she's getting a lot of backlash.
She's getting a lot of hate and I want
to take this from an balanced approach.
Um and let's just watch it for ourel
inshallah and see what we can learn
because we do have to be just and be
balanced. So, I haven't seen a video.
We're going to watch it together in see
if this was right or wrong. Let's see.
Here we go.
>> I'm currently at Tel Aviv airport.
Probably wondering what I'm doing here.
I've come to visit Masha and it's been a
dream to come. I've always wanted to
come, but the story's kind of put me
off, but I'm here to share my story of
immigration and whatnot and security.
And maybe that will motivate some people
to come because you always hear about
the horror stories, but not the good
ones. So let me begin. Um when we got
here uh went through immigration like
normal um I got my you apply for a visa
beforehand which is like5 or 6 I believe
and they get back to you within 24 hours
but you here at um border control they
give you like a green slip and you need
to scan that to get out. So I got mine
immediately. It was basic questions. How
long were you here for? Why are you
here? Um when's your flight back? Where
are you staying? general stuff which
absolutely fine, absolutely normal. My
husband on the other hand um got moved
to a side. We were in a waiting room. I
got to wait with him. We were in a
waiting room for about 2 hours. I'd say
2 and 1 half hours. Luckily, I had
snacks, but even though I had snacks,
which I think is kind of nice. Um they
gave me a coffee. Um they gave me a
cheese sandwich. And the um worker also
came to me and said to me like, "Do you
need anything else?" um your husband
won't be long, you know, stuff like that
even though I was in communication with
him because you do get free Wi-Fi access
at the airport. But like I heard so much
horrible stories that it was kind of
putting me off from visiting before at
hand. But now I feel like I should share
this positive story.
>> Okay, now let's be balanced here guys.
You guys know my works and stuff that
I've done. Uh you know, not that I need
any praise. I don't think I've done
nothing enough to what I should have
done for Palestinians and I'm ashamed of
that to be honest with you. It's not
something to be proud of. Uh but the
reason I'm saying that is because you
guys know my stance on the matter but we
have to be just and we have to be
balanced. Um there's we need to look at
it from one perspective. The first
perspective is the sister is saying u
that there's a lot of people that have
horror stories. I'll be honest with you
people tell me visit Mash and I'm like
look I don't think they will let me in
in any way shape or form. Okay. So to me
it's like I hear horror stories as well
and there are people and it is important
for us as the um to visit there. They
don't want us to visit there. We need to
visit there as often as we can. So
looking for it from that sister's
perspective and assuming the best of the
believer we have to be like hold on a
second yes [snorts] she's trying to do a
video her intentions are good that she's
saying to the people I was afraid I came
here I had a pleasant experience now
we'll come to the pleasant experience
thing to say look don't be afraid come
so her intention is what to tell the
other Muslims don't be afraid these
things do happen however it is pleasant
come and visit maka we have to be just
and honest and say that is good
intentions and she means well we cannot
come and attack her and be like oh no
this that from that perspective however
my dear sister just see it from another
perspective as well and I'll give a
scenario and I want to talk about the
holocaust yes uh that happened in uh
Congo yes oh yeah when I mean holocaust
holocaust happened in different places
as well it happened in Nazi Germany also
happened in uh in Congo yes uh king leap
leapod I massacred 10 million congalles
yes 10 million congalles and he will
punish the parents if they were not
picking the cotton or in the farm
whatever it is properly. He will cut the
limbs of their children and put it in
front of them to say work harder. This
is how evil these people are and they
want to make us terrorists. They are
evil and also we know the holocaust that
happened in Nazi Germany. So let me just
give an understanding just imagine for a
second my dear sister for those who have
and the ones who are you know pal pro
Palestinian campaigners etc. who who are
upset with you. Just understand it from
their perspective because you are
affecting the cause unintentionally. You
mean well we have no doubt about that my
sister. However, just check this out. If
I was to travel to Nazi Germany when the
Holocaust was happening I landed in the
airport and I said the following. Look,
there are horror stories etc etc blah
blah blah. I've landed in Berlin. Yeah.
And I'm just going through the airport.
the Nazi soldiers. Um, you know, when I
was there, I've heard horror stories of,
you know, if you can come and visit. So
far, they've been pleasant. My wife has
been kind of interrogated for 2 and a
half hours. But one of the Nazi soldiers
was kind enough to give us a coffee and
it's been pleasant.
Do you do you see do you see what has
happened there? It doesn't matter how
pleasant those people are. They may be
pleasant because they're doing their
duty or whatever or whatever reason that
may be. There is a holocaust happening
in Berlin. Yes. Or whatever. In the
concentration camps and there are Jewish
innocent people, men, women, and
children in you want to call it the gas
chambers being massacred miles down the
road.
Is it correct? I understand the
intention, but everyone would go crazy
that if I was to say a Nazi soldier,
it's been pleasant. He gave me coffee.
We understand your intention, sister,
but it tarnishes the cause. Now, again,
she's telling the truth. So, it's a such
a thin line where it's like, you're
right, but wrong intentions are right.
It just came across wrong. It's such a
thin line. But this is the problem, my
dear sister. Same thing with Russia. If
you go to Russia and say, you know what,
look, I landed there. People make Russia
TV, but I landed there. The Russian um
soldiers or or for example, immigration
or whatever, they were very pleasant.
They gave me coffee. The western media
will be like, "Oh, that's the point
here." And they have massacred brothers
and sisters. And I'm again, I don't
believe the sisters should get hate.
It's just that it would have been better
not to be done. Better. Now, is she
lying? No. We have to be honest and say
that's her experience and that is true.
She's not lying. However, it's just
distasteful. And I believe the sister
did not mean that. And I believe she
meant well that people should go to Mash
Ala. It just came across wrong, my dear
sister. That's why we have to be a
little bit careful and I do this as a
social media influencer. I fall for
this. My intentions are well the
delivery and the timing is a bit bad.
Yes. So I have to own up to and I've
done that as well. So I don't believe
that sis should get hate. It was a
genuine honest take from her that came
across wrong and distasteful and yeah
that's all I wanted to say inshallah. So
brothers and sisters in please please
guys be very careful cuz this can harm
her. She didn't mean that. So let's be
gentle towards believers and be a little
bit soft inshallah. Okay, she meant
well, came across wrong. But let's leave
it at that. Inshallah, that's all I
wanted to say. Inshallah, may Allah subh
protect our sister and her husband and
that it is at least used as a form that
people can be more have the courage to
travel to masaka. Till next time.